il me semble pas des clandestins
la belle année selon cathy sur un air de
reggae
il y avait le tirailleur d'afilias la
descente sommes solidaires avec les sans
papiers de france parce que tout le
monde
ils sont pas sans papiers parce qu'il
l'aurait voulu mais parce que c'est la
loi qui a fabriqué les stations donné
dix ans maintenant de 30 ce soir et
aujourd'hui étaient présents mais aussi
les chinois ils n'ont pas d'habitude à
se manifester dans cette fois on a en a
plus de choix au bon moment si au volant
on doit vivre il faut quand le manifeste
ils réclament tous une annulation
soit il à régulariser tous les sans
papiers
davantage
sensibiliser aussi l'opinion publique et
particulièrement
sigler
et voyez qu'on fait différent
d'inspiration
jean et valeurs humaines est aussi
intransigeant moi je dis attention
je sais que nos échéances doctorale je
sais qu'il ya une façon du front
national mais en tout état de cause il
faut pas prendre les immigrés en otage
et la mobilisation dans des sans papiers
ne s'est pas dès ce soir entre 11 et 15
mille personnes ont à nouveau alors à
peine un manifestant aux gens